what we are doing right now uh we are
helping to build customer software
starting from the scratching once the
cases or sometimes we have you know
started in from the middle of that
development in order to help them change
the world so i believe that's that's the
reason why we founded the company and
it's the still same reason why we run
why we are running it right now
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet andrei
sambir the ceo of linkup studio
andrei sanbeer is the ceo of a top
software development company located in
ukraine in his 20s andriy founded and
led its link up studio product driven
software development and design company
that today are one of the best sas
companies in ukraine having gained over
8 plus years of working on digital
projects he found important to share his
experience that's how he founded
building digital product podcast the
show for startups and entrepreneurs
about the things andre would like
someone to tell him at the beginning
isn't it crazy that we're here talking
about innovation talking about startups
and tech and and we start the
conversation by you know by affirming
that it's good that we didn't have an
airstrike today i just i just found it
um i found that it was it was meaningful
enough to to stop and ponder on that for
a second hey but andre you're you're a
technologist to running the company link
up within ukraine and so tell me a
little bit about you know your journey
and and what link up is
sure of course uh so
uh i found link up when i was 20 years
old so you know we have this kind of
classic story of the company that
started in the dormitory with you know a
few friends who was who was who were
very naive first of all very name very
unexperienced in that time
but what i noticed
and why i started the company
as the software developer in that time i
was young but i already have been
experiencing a software developer for
five years i start very very early
uh i noticed that lots of these people
in ukraine who come into their jobs as
the developers designers and et cetera i
mean people in tech
uh they are
you know uh applying to their jobs like
you know from eight to five something
like this and his job for them
and i saw lots of that uh you know
people with great opportunities peoples
with great ideas uh which they are
coming uh you know to ukraine to build
their startups uh some of them failed
some of them succeeded uh but some
something that i used to miss that time
and and still in some sense i'm missing
that i wanted to build a company
uh with tech professionals
who helping those peoples with the ideas
and with their businesses
to really build it you know there are
people and my customers right now
there are people
with the awesome ideas with blowing mind
you know things the changing businesses
around them and to be honest i can say
that some of their business actually
changing the world in the tech
perspectives
and what we are doing right now uh we
are helping to build them the software
starting from the scratching once the
cases or sometimes we have you know
started in from the middle of that
development in order to help them change
the world so i believe that's that's the
reason why we founded the company and
it's the still same reason why we run
why we are running it right now
so we finally those
and
really great businesses and helping them
and so we're talking about this um
you know this gap between you know
innovation and the the ability to
actually execute
technologically and so you're finding
that there that you know you have these
people that want to innovate that want
to build these great products but
they're lacking that perhaps the
technological capacity and so what are
what is sort of the this medium in which
you work with them is it is it a project
based is it retainer based how how do
you how do you manage the collaboration
with these innovators
i understand
sure well that's actually depends from
you know the type of every project sound
like there are like for us there are two
main types in case in case you would
like it to categorize there are startups
and there are existing businesses so i
mean and the approach to to them in some
sense similar but in some sense is
different and i will try to explain
right now so let's take the startup uh
usually people come in with the with the
ideas uh and what what people have they
have understanding of the market uh they
have some kind of the connections in the
domain area uh for example i can i
remember the great startup who came to
us with a great idea super simple idea
and you know as you know everything
genius is super simple uh they wanted to
automate uh
buying of the goods in the shopping
store in case you are buying food for
the large group or for the large group
or you know so there are you know
different people different dietary
restrictions different directions and
you know people usually buying too much
potato too much something that they
throw it out so they just created this
simple excel spreadsheet
and uh you know and and this was the
solving of the problem but the exam
spreadsheet was not usable uh very often
break you know that's formulas all of
that so they created the idea okay how
about we build the software
so a great example they knew the market
they perfectly knew that business model
is working uh they knew how to make it
monetize but they don't know how to
build the software itself and this is
the moment where we came in
so we built this software from the
scratch and right now this is the
successful startup uh working on the
market they have the mobile app they
have the website application they are
user-based they're still growing
and this is how we help them in that
moment so like uh we listed what they
wanted to do we telling them is it
technically possible at all because
sometimes people
come in with the very genius idea but
they just technically kind of either
impossible either it goes so much that
you know business wise it's impossible
so this is this is the example about the
startup and the second example can be
about the business so imagine you like
we have the company in the new york
unfortunately cannot mention the name
because of the nda but in fact they are
processing
thousands thousands of documents every
day in the real estate area and this
company like as far as i know they have
up to 15 employees thousands of requests
every day why because we build the
software for them that automate like 70
on this process
and you know and and and they they can
do it and uh by you know by the
technology we help them to stay on the
market and not fail you know some of the
competitors that tried to hire you know
more people to proceed all of that and
they bankrupt these companies survived
and actually successfully growing
because they use technology to solve
their problems
interesting so you're touching on this
idea that today in today's world pretty
much
you know any you know if you really want
to be relevant
you need technology right i mean you
need technology to be able to work at
the scale that that a business needs to
work at and so everybody but there's
still no it's not obviously accessible
to everybody and so you're here bridging
this gap if somebody has a great a great
idea or a great business you can help
bring them up to you up to speed
and how do you see though that word you
know long term because at the end you
know technology is a core part of the
business and the end you're working with
them sort of as an as an outsourced
model so they're working on the business
you're working on the technology um
is does it is it is you know is it
healthy relationship does it work you
know long term where the technology
lives outside of their core business or
their core team how do you manage that
relationship so that there is always
this constant communication and business
understanding so as i mentioned in the
beginning you know lots of software
engineers that i saw in ukraine they
used to go to the work you know from
eight to five you know and that was like
okay i've done my job uh i go in and the
something that i would like to change
that approach
of my developer and that's what we're
doing right now like all of my people
they're like we called ourselves
approved focus or product oriented if
you want so when we working with someone
uh so you just mentioned taking
technology outside well this is not
something uh like we like to say uh we
always trying to be the part of the
you know our our customer member i
actually just kind of hate the word
customer and more like work partners you
know like
and it's starting from everything from
the relationship like we should have so
like my engineers in case we have the
team of engineers designers qa
they are very deeply integrated into
business of our customer very deeply and
it's starting from you know starting
from how we're working every day
finishing with how we're drinking you
know when we launch something in case we
have some small parties and so on you
know we're visiting each other so i
would not tell that working like with
the leak up is some kind of the
technology outside and something that i
uh telling to my employees when i hire
them i tell them that look in our
corporate corporate culture
uh we let in
uh smart people doing smart job and
everything else supposed to be automated
so like even inside of our company we're
constantly working on everything that
they possibly have to make you know like
we wanted to focus on on the products we
built all that you know either way says
building all of that all of that other
stuff it's all automated as maximum as
possible even inside of our company the
same we're doing for our customer
okay so it sounds so you're saying every
organization needs automation every
organization needs to use external tools
you you know you're just changing the
threshold of when that happens so for
example for you as a tech company you're
saying my threshold is that i need some
of these you know the these common tools
like billing and invoicing and hr
management we're going to use other sas
products for that which obviously pretty
much every other company uses as well in
the tech space
but you're saying but
we can actually provide a different we
can increase the threshold so that
companies who actually need technology
for their business needs will also get
it as you work on these
on these products and these solutions
how involved do you need to be in the
business or or in understanding
the business because for for instance
you know if we're building consumer
products right we there's a lot of
emphasis on on the messaging and the
look the design the customer experience
and there's a lot of quick
quick you know back and forth does it
need to happen a lot of a b tests that
need to happen how do you work with the
companies to manage that well uh
like
just to make it more interesting when we
just started i personally was involved
in every project that we that we built
and you know that was very exciting very
interesting because you learn so much
like you
you know you're having the call in the
morning and you're you know you're
focused on one domain like in the
evening you have different call you
focus on the different domain obviously
when companies starting to grow and
scaling like when we're not 10 people in
the room but right now we are like one
like more near 100 people in the room
right now link up size obviously i
cannot manage every product because then
and you know capacity and productivity
low down i i can you know you you can be
focused only on a few things at one time
or actually you can be focused on one
thing at one time but you just you know
changing the focus sometimes um right
now lincoln work like as i told like
each of the product they have their own
team and each of the team they have
they must have business analyst someone
who deeply deeply dived into their
domain area we cannot help you in case
we don't understand your business and i
honestly tell them like on the first
calls i'm telling you guys i'm not
profession professional like in the real
estate in the gaming uh in the
cryptocurrency
uh but you will
you will tell me uh we will work with
your managers every day and like you
will learn so the business analysts they
at us to understand the core of our
our customers uh like you mentioned the
design ui ux this lack are supposed to
be there because they need to understand
right now building the technology
without that well in case we were
talking about the technology but you
know
where it's supposed to be people
interaction obviously uh but it
it cannot be without the design like how
apple managed to you know uh beat
everyone great design so so right now
it's impossible like our company right
now is the first company in ukraine
based on clients.com version in ukraine
so we're doing like based on their
rating we are on the first and it seems
to me the third one on the world
uh but you know change rating always
changes right i can i can i can be wrong
but still and design and business
analyst is the super big key you know
lots of our uh you know customers who
come into us they are searching like
like do you have the like i don't know
react native engineers rack native is
one of the type of the technologies that
exist on the market and i am always
telling yes we do but are you sure that
your problem is luck love rack native
engineers give us please some time and
we kind of wanted to dive deeper and
when we do dive deeper we understand
that okay you really need this
engineered however can we help you
slightly change the process and you know
it's it's basically the business tactic
we kind of give in one engineer in the
half year there are 10 people
you know because it's not about just
hands it's about brands i always tell
them like we're not selling like people
we're not selling hands we sell it brand
and process and and consultancy so some
kind of the expertise because you always
can hire team uh
in-house and very often you actually
need it i i must be very honest and
transferred uh however um like when
you're hiring us you're hiring like i
don't know one again react native
engineer in case he got the problem in
case your product got technical problem
he has the whole community of you know
30 engineers in our company with who he
can consult and then bring in that
solution to your product and tech
updates of your product is its speed is
extremely important like we will we will
have the new iphone so or we already
have the new iphone i don't know
i just use the also
so like and and that's it you need to
update everything you need to update
everything immediately and in case you
are slower than your competitor you're
done
so that that that's
like okay that makes sense
i i i love the distinction and
and revisiting that question of
in-house versus outsource because i
think that's a
a question that that i definitely don't
answer and i think most most
entrepreneurs don't really know how to
navigate and it's sort of you know with
this ad hoc decision that is made you
know on the fly when you need something
done it's at a certain point
but but it requires a lot of thought
right because you're you need to build a
different system around it a different
culture around it you need to mitigate
some risk and to and to into plan ahead
as well so what do you reck what is sort
of your recommendation to founders or
from your experience what have you
observed was helpful
as as entrepreneurs make the decision to
either go in-house
or go outside well i mean i believe
everyone's expecting the answer uh like
go outsource because i'm personally the
ceo of outsource company however i will
tell you the next bunch uh it's very
good to have at least the
you know see the chief technical officer
in house
and from my experience i can tell you
this one in case there was someone in
house and then they hire us
uh to to help them
uh it work much more smoother and i tell
you why because of the trust obviously
when you start working with the new
people you don't trust them not because
you are bad or they attack just because
that that's natural you know you need
some kind of the icebreaker and you
really have the great trust relationship
like in one one and a half years before
that it's it's always you know you you
you reading the contracts you're like uh
like i don't remember what stated on the
contract with someone who i work in more
than three years i really don't and they
don't too however every new people they
obviously read it and that's okay this
is the business uh work uh however when
you have someone in house some some part
of the team or at least one cto it's
much more easier because this guy is the
tactical professional and he see that
you're outsourced stevens okay like he's
kind of proven
he he can prove to you expertise so in
case you're a non-technical guy
and uh you you you make the decision who
you want to hire in case you have the
technical founder it's easier for us to
build the trust because this technical
founder telling okay work with the club
they they doing the great job uh and
this icebreaking is usually taking
longer in case there are no such kind of
the person on the
on on the in-house basically on on the
customer side however this is not the
you know like deal breaker uh we
obviously can work without someone you
know uh who is in house still but but to
be honest yeah this heartbreaking period
just taking longer wishes normally i
believe because you know us
people acting very differently some of
them understand technology somewhere
they are not uh that's why by the way
our business analysts they have special
uh you know they have specialists on the
calls where they're supposed to explain
all technical issues in case we see that
in case we understand that customers
don't don't understand technical world
and this is also fine because that's why
we exist i mean
otherwise we would not have no job
because everyone can code
himself you know why software engineers
supposed to exist
so
you are you know obviously you you
could have chosen to go and create you
know your own company with a specific
business need and scale it up as a
traditional startup but you're choosing
to run link up which obviously is a big
success but it still requires a decision
why why did you decide that what is sort
of your you know the the internal
decision that you had with yourself to
to do link up as this company rather
than a a startup that's dedicated
well i believe this is
one of the big chunk of that decision
it's uh because you know we've been the
area where our center i mean it's it's
it's called like the mecca of our source
there are lots of outsourced companies
so this model was clear understandable
and when you go into the university you
have your teachers who are ceos and you
you know you you look at those teachers
and you're like i want to be like
them
you know
so so that's one of the things so you
kind of understandable uh
by the way i must tell that except the
link up you know link up itself we try
we used to try to launch like few
startups they didn't unfortunately
succeed but that's okay you know nothing
you know you know that there is a low
probability of the six feedback and lead
cup have you know each of our
customer each of our product it's it's
it's small world and it's one moment i
just do understand that for me
super interesting to have my mind inside
of each of this product that just focus
on something one i personally
consider myself as you know as
as i put in some kind of the effort and
i'm putting some kind of my soul into
each of the product my company working
with i can you can randomly give me tell
me any customer we do and i can explain
how this particular product changing the
world or will change the world in case
it's in under development right now i
mean uh you know like
during these nine years i believe i used
to touch someone more deeper someone
just touched you know more than 100
products honestly
and
right for me yes that's wow that's
really a lot of me right now when
someone new comment i mean i sometimes i
feel like you know this
groundhog day you know this field where
emc repeating and it's very common story
when the people come and have this as i
told like we need engineers i'm like
okay guys can can we just talk give me
one hour what just give me just one hour
to speak to you
and and then i said okay how about you
do i mean don't pay me don't even hire
me just just slightly change this please
and then they come in after two months
and said okay andre you know your advice
actually was good can we move forward
and it's like of course we can
so and and for me this is this is super
exciting because you're getting all
these dozen different experience and by
having all of this you can be much more
productive in what you're doing and i
believe it's not only me that's also the
engineers that work in my company
designers base and and so on and we
sometimes we just sorted people between
projects in order to exchange this
experience and we have inner events to
exchange the experience and that's why
we have like really very good engineers
okay you know some fun advertising but
to be honest but that's how it's
incredible
i uh
no no i think that i i think that it's
awesome and i can definitely just see
how you're how excited you are about
this so i think it's just really it's
really fun for my end to see this
excitement and
and then sharing that passion with you
for these 20 minutes and i really
appreciate you coming here and spending
this time i think that you know the
outsource model obviously it's a really
important one in our ecosystem it's an
enabler for companies who who want to
have more meaningful technology but
don't have the necessarily necessary the
capacity or the ability to and and and i
think that you're doing a great service
to them and i think it's also awesome
you know the way that you manage to grow
this into such an amazing team going
from you know and scaling this up and
and and doing it in ukraine and and
that's obviously a story for another
episode but um for now i really wish you
best of luck with link up and and stay
safe and i hope that everything it works
out well and i'm sure that it will and
so thank you very very much andre yeah
thank you for
for listening to me and i hope that was
enjoyable and interesting
it was fantastic thank you
[Music]
you